[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israels
heute gibt drei cocktails dyballa nein
natürlich nicht so aus geht es bei x
wanne und bei kelly mist los
liebe grüße aber ich mache natürlich
familienfreundliche kinderfreundliche
getränke für den sommer nämlich drei
getränke ohne zusätzlichen weißen
industriezucker getränke die man einfach
den tag über gut verzehren kann
vor allem sollte man ja auch jetzt
gerade an den warmen tagen viel trinken
und ich muss mich selber immer dazu
zwingen viel wasser zu trinken ich bin
so ein wassertrinker wenn man auch eine
bwt anlage im haus das heißt ich trinke
einfach den ganzen tag leitungswasser
aber irgendwann wird mir das dann auch
wie soll ich sagen zu viel zu langweilig
und ich brauche auch mal was mit
geschmack ich bin nicht der typ der dann
schnell zu limonade greift ich bin eher
der typ nimmt dann zitrone mit ins
wasser oder mal so ein rosmarin stengel
ich versuche mich da relativ zuckerfrei
zu ernähren weil wir den tag über viel
wie zucker essen und ich will bei
getränken muss es nicht sein da reicht
mir wirklich auch die frucht süße
deswegen habe ich mir überlegt machen
wir jetzt alles erstmal wassermelonen
limonade wassermelone hat ja von sich
aus schon viel zucker und ist schon süß
genug ist ein toller geschmack auch dem
man da erzeugen kann
ich nehme da für diese wassermelonen
limette himbeeressig und dann brauche
ich noch zwei tut zwei zutaten und die
finde ich draußen im garten nämlich
himbeeren und minze der gema kurz im
garten
es sei witzig denn die minze habe ich
hier eingesetzt jetzt kann ich sie da
vorne bei mir schon die ist gewachsen
bis dahin minze ist als ein phänomen ist
wie unkraut aber ich liebe es deswegen
habe ich eingesetzt egal
[Musik]
macht dann 350 bitte ok dann kann ich
jetzt hier die wassermelone nehmen die
weiß auch schon im kühlschrank also ist
es schön kalt
das ist auch eine mit wenig kernen
testkäufer
vielleicht haben diese anders gemacht
ihr könnt auch auslassen aber so macht
mir spaß ich habe es vielleicht auf tik
tok sie natürlich eine seriöse quelle
aber er funktioniert also wichtig ist
man sollte die wassermelone vorher
abwaschen
das habe ich auch gemacht damit die
schale außen eben auch sauber ist
ja hallo geht doch
vielleicht kann man auch den locker
nehmen den prinzip einfach das wasser
mit uns live zerkleinern und ausfällen
geht bestimmt noch mitläufer so den rest
kratzt sich gleich noch aus aber mit dem
lässt sich recht gut zerkleinern
also der grund warum ich das ganze nicht
püriert haben sind natürlich die kerne
werden der wassermelone habt ohne kerne
könnt ihr einfach ein pürierstab nehmen
ich möchte aber die schwarzen kenne
nicht verkleinern sondern möchte einfach
raus 7 oder zusagen die will ich nicht
in der limonade
ich nehme jetzt hier einfach die flotte
lotte ihr könnt aber auch im sieb nehmen
und das ganze durch streichen wenn ihr
aber sagt die kerne stören euch gar
nicht dann lassen wir einfach drin
aber wenn man halt das getränk strohhalm
trinken will dann da ist es schwierig
also mich würd's nicht stören
deswegen sage ich trotzdem wenn man sie
entfernen kann
aber mich persönlich wird es nicht
stören dich nur ich bin auch kein mensch
der glaubt dass wir mal ein wasser
verschluckt die im buch bleiben und
waffe melone wächst habe ich schon
gehört er sogar von dem arzt der ali
glaubt daran
als kind haben dass seine eltern gesagt
[Musik]
also den rest hier werde ich einfach
löffeln hat trotzdem noch genug
geschmack dabei und das hier wird jetzt
die limonade
hier gebe ich jetzt für den geschmack
noch limette dazu im grab marias
besprochen aus dem rest machen wir uns
los ist einfach einfrieren in so einem
einteiler da geht es recht schnell und
dann ja und dann kann man das so lächeln
als lastesel meter drauf limettensaft
ist drin bei mir kommt jetzt wie gesagt
noch minze dazu und im prinzip könnt ihr
dann diese mischung in den kühlschrank
stellen und einfach durchziehen lassen
was ich jetzt gleich machen werde
einfach noch himbeeressig dazu für den
geschmack kommt ist eure und frucht süße
auch mit rein und entweder könnt ihr das
jetzt im kühlschrank einfach ziehen
lassen für ein paar stunden was jetzt
machen werde
ich mag nämlich die die limonade
praktisch mit soda spritzig und ich habe
hier einfach eine flasche mit der ich so
da machen kann als einfach ein super
mega und da ist der vorteil dass wenn
ich jetzt hier die masse einfüllen und
dann eben mit dem solar charger
sozusagen aktivieren
dann geht der geschmack der minze und
elli meter direkt in die wasserwelle
rein und ich muss nicht ziehen lassen
also im prinzip so wie ein vakuum ihrer
den ich ja auch oft benutzt die vakuum
schublade da zählt auch sofort das aroma
zum beispiel ins fleisch oder ins obst
und gemüse ein
und hier ist es genau so da kann ich
gleich die limonade servieren ohne zu
warten
jetzt muss ich sie nur ein fühlen
und wie sich beim rheinfall am schönen 7
damit einfach die frucht stückchen
entfernt werden und die düse nicht
verstopfen
und jetzt halb halb mit wasser auffüllen
damit einfach auch nicht zu süß wird
hier gebe ich jetzt auch nur zwei
minzblätter ein paket sind die männer
auch da die dürfen gleich den limonade
probieren
hier mache ich jetzt in bern rein und
mintzel und schlimm mit witz und deko
morath wollte probieren sparkling
watermelon man hat aber echt ne geile
farbe hätte gern noch ein bisschen denn
rein gar ein wow
wir sind ein traum wahr heißt energie
west capital richtig genial machen drei
getränke ohne zugesetzten zucker nur aus
frucht zu sein
es wird ja eiswürfel die eiswürfel
vergessen
aber sorry ihr wart die vorkoster jetzt
kann das rezept wirklich machen
okay ich mache noch zwei dann rufe ich
euch und die hin große flasche und die
kinder waren auf dem garten war schon so
ich mache hier und finden es 1 1
das zweite getränk wird ein mango
maracuja ice t
dafür nehme ich als basis grünen tee ihr
könnt auch schwarz teilnehmen oder auch
einen ganz anderen de was er gerne
möglich habe jetzt hier einfach so einen
losen grünen tee ihr könnte brauchen
beutel t verwenden und davon brauche ich
etwa einen liter
eine reife mango für reife maracuja
science würfel basilikum und zitrone
ich habe jetzt hier mein wasser schon
aufkochen lassen und bisschen abkühlen
lassen
grüner tee sollte nämlich nicht mit
kochend heißem wasser übergossen werden
und ich brauche jetzt zwei teelöffel pro
liter also wirklich auch noch ganz wenig
und ich mache das jetzt so damit das
ganze schneller abkühlt gieße ich jetzt
hier nicht einen liter heißes wasser
drauf sondern einfach ungefähr ja so 200
250 lass das kurz durchziehen und
western mit den eiswürfeln einfach kalt
bekommen ganz einfach und ihnen der
zwischenzeit kümmere ich mich schon mal
um die mango die kann ich nämlich hier
rechts und links vom stein
schaut einfach ausschneiden und die
sollte halt wirklich schön reif sein
also schön weich einfach und jetzt
könnte ich hier im glas ansetzen und
zack scheele
mango wird da noch schön püriert
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich hier schon mal ein
paar eiswürfel rhein geben denn der tee
ist es fertig
[Musik]
jetzt einfach auf einen liter auffüllen
dann kommt hier das mango pürieren das
wird automatisch damit da einfach zur
sicherheit keine stückchen mehr sind im
behälter rasch aus ich fühle mich gerade
wie in seiner versuchs werkstatt mit
diesem ganzen idee hält haben
so und dann auf jeden fall die
basilikumblätter noch mit rein
ich hatte das ja schon mal erklärt wenn
man bei minze und kräutern und basilikum
egal was die blätter in die hand nimmt
und auf klatscht entfalten sich die
ätherischen öle besser und dann kommt
der geschmack besser durch und dann
brauche ich nur eine karaffe die hole
ich noch ganz kurz und dann kommen noch
die maracuja und der zitronensaft 1
aber dann ist fertig
über der maracuja einfach hier dieses
fleischs löffel und mit dazu geben
da mag ich die kerne ganz gerne deswegen
das motto für jeden fall drin
[Musik]
und die sollten auf jeden fall außen so
richtig hässlich sein dann sind sie
schön reich und wenn ihr die limonade
dann trinkt auf jeden fall auf die kerne
beißen weil die haben echt sondern
richtig tollen geschmack
die finde ich wahnsinnig als ich kenne
viele die dann weg 7 und aussortieren
aber die sind halt echt schon richtig
lecker katze mit joghurt zum beispiel so
gut wie so ein natürlicher bubble tea wo
man einfach drauf bist und es ist
explodiert so im mund ja
[Musik]
dann ist mein zweites getränk gibt es
auch fertig und ich würde sagen ich
lasse dieses getränk benny probieren
denn benny hat mir den grünen tee
gesponsert der sponsor des heutigen
tages ich hatte eigentlich ebenso ein
richtig schönes sektglas aber dann
dachte ich mir es ist vielleicht nicht
männlich genug deswegen habe ich jetzt
einen großen kelch also maracuja mango
limonade gehen eigentlich eigentlich ein
ice t ist es limonade wenn es praktisch
übrig ist aber es gibt ja auch barclays
thema dieses nutzbar klingen was ist es
eistee oder auf grüner tee mit eis ist
drei leiste mit basilikum mann bist so
ein bisschen ziehen lassen damit der
basilikum oder man nimmt eben von
sondern sie flaschen probieren
dieser werkstoff sehr frisch sehr lecker
für zucker ist es glaube ich gerade ganz
gut für ein sommer gerne haben weil
sonst trinkt man heute noch mehr und
meine worte ich bin ja auch noch für das
werk getränke machen die einfach ohne
zugesetzten zucker auskommen deswegen
ich finde auch die also die süße aus der
mango finde ich passt hat diesen cars
wieder herausschmecken wollte ich
natürlich auch dass ich meine arango und
marco ja das hat ja jetzt auch mehr also
wenn man möchte dass der basilikum noch
mehr raus schmeckt einfach ein bisschen
ziehen lassen im kühlschrank und dann
kommt er auch besser durch so mache ich
das jetzt noch perfekt und dann gibt es
jetzt noch getränke nummer drei und
dafür gäbe nochmal im garten denn ich
brauche lavendel
[Musik]
gott dass hier wird jetzt im prinzip
eine apfelschorle aromatisierte ihr
könnt aber auch statt apfelsaft
natürlich auch wieder am tee aufbrühen
oder einen anderen saft leben
aber wenn jetzt hier den apfelsaft den
haben wir sozusagen gerettet
wir hatten da nämlich von der firma von
stiefkind die ganzen apfelsaft flaschen
gekauft weil der praktisch kurz vor dem
mindest ablauf mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum
war und die gastronomie die hat ja
nichts mehr abgekauft haben wir den
gerettet und sozusagen an kindergärten
und schulen und soziale einrichtungen
verteilt wie schön muss sein und ein
paar flaschen haben wir noch hier in der
firma das jetzt mit sprudel aufgießen
regionales war von kevin und da kommt
jetzt meine lavendel rein
ich muss sagen wenn ihr möchtet dass der
lavendel dass das praktisch ganz viel
geschmack abgibt dann könnt ihr den
lavendel mit dem apfelsaft ein bisschen
einkochen
ich glaube das mache ich tatsächlich
auch damit einfach nur ein bisschen mehr
lavendel geschmack kommt aber ein paar
gebe ich hier auch wieso zur deko rhein
und dem groß- marin auch mit denen auch
einfach so ein bisschen vertreiben und
so weil ich mag lavendel geschmack ganz
gerne und groß machen geschmack auch bei
dem wehr setzt so intensiv das gebe ich
jetzt hier so rein und wie gesagt ein
paar gebe ich einen kleinen topf
bisschen apfelsaft muss es gar nicht so
knapp sein dann am ende dazu
und wirklich nur ganz wenig hierzu ganz
kurz erwärmen das ist wie sowieso im tee
einfach ein bisschen ziehen kann schon
schöne farbverlauf
ach ja die schöne optik zerstöre ich
nicht ich mache ein gläschen noch einmal
separat zum probieren okay
[Musik]
hier schön durchgezogen das kommt jetzt
hier auch praktisch mit rein
ich sehe jetzt hier eine portion so ich
glaube das darf dann sarah probieren
sarah liegt der blumen und lavendel und
kräuter und rosmarin schön mit dem
farbverlauf sarah bitte geh ich hatte so
ein bumerang
[Musik]
ich muss sagen das ist das schönste
getränke konsumieren und ich würde denn
ich glaube mein handy dabei hätte würde
ich sie male im sektor story laden
ich dachte sagt wenn ich mal heirate
möchte ich das als hochzeits getränk 516
von alkohol
aber da kann man mit sicherheit gut das
habe ich aber schon mal gemacht ich hab
mal lavendel sirup gemacht und den kann
man dann auch praktisch mit mit sekt und
so weiter aufschließen gibt es auch auf
meinem kanal oder ist gut
okay die deko ist zwar schön
man muss halt mit röhrchen vorstoß in
der nase händel bush eine sehr lecker
der lavendel schmecken richtig gut drauf
der rosmarin und dem ist noch bis
letzten also dass in der karaffe das
zieht jetzt schon ganz gut also drei
getränke für den sommer zum mehr trinken
wie erfrischend sind die erfrischend
sind gut schmecken abwechslungsreich
schreibt mir gerne mal welcher dieser
drei getränke welches dieser drei
getränke euer favorit ist und ob er noch
weitere getränke wünsche habt wenn ihr
wollt aus meinem team kam so ein
bisschen der wunsch nach bubble tea ich
find auch ruhig aber vielleicht liegen
was er mehrere lecker hin ok zara gehört
nicht zum team alles ja ich aber das
kriegen wir bestimmt besser hin also
wenn jetzt zu süßen ja wenn erst sehen
möchte dann können wir das gerne weil
meine kinder also samira und murat die
sind schon auch immer so dass diese
orwell team wollen wir haben und ich bin
so fließt also viel spaß machen bis zum
nächsten mal
das ist uns auch aus drehen synchron
links rechts am schluss noch ganz okay
[Musik]